Có lỡ, có lỡ.
Cái này, có do accurately.
Dạng sáng quan mình 1 2, 8 năm học29, trong khoảng trình tân chắc kým xóa trên tiến cứ lụng một đọn qua sã trình bong.
Chẳng kể sẽ gió thông suy chè, phòng kể sẽ gió thông công an tình đường này,
tính hiện kìm tra hình chính xe 1 tô bình số xong mới bê chính bày xó không ỉnh ích,
giờ đến nơi đây, 2 mì xó tuổi, 1 đường này, biêu khiến,
qua kìm tra, lực lượng trích năng phát hiện trong tùng chữ độ của xe có 1 thục vựng mồ này.
Bên trong cất giấu, một gọi nhi lồng giảng tuổi giết chứa tinh thị một chẳng đi làm mặt truy ra,
một cân tử liy, dụng khủ sử dụng mặt truy, làm việc với tổ công tác,
để khai nhận số tinh thị trình đã mặt truy ra, mô về để xử dụng.
Tổ công tác đã phó hộ công an sá trường bong là bình bản bắt người phạm tự của tăng
về những vì tăng chữ trải phép trích mặt truy, đông thử tạm giữ,
nhưng phòng tổng bộ tăng bật theo đúng quy định.
Hình vùng việc đã được bàn rau cho công an sá trường bong tiếp tục đưa ra,
sử liy theo thông quyền.